wir können zufrieden sein dass ich jetzt
ein schöner effekt habe dass sich
entspannt bin uns nach vorne
[Musik]
kaiser der entspannte gold brummifahrer
brian ihr bei uns im studio schön
entspannt schick und morgen hast du denn
grundsätzlich für das anliegen klima und
so weiter
verständnis selbstverständlich haben wir
nicht so nah wir haben alle einen
beitrag dazu leisten das hängt eine
trennung an oder dass man mit der bvg
fährt etc pp seine sachen länger trägt
als nur einmal und das gehört alles was
dazu aber jeder einzelne muss sich daran
beteiligen und nicht so eine show zu
machen wie ein gefährt in mainz